من العام الماضي ان احنا متابعين معاكم
اخبار الاقالات اللي بتعلنها شركات
التكنولوجيا بحق موظف فيها احداث اليوم
شركه التكنولوجيا بيبال اللي دخلت على خط
تصريح الموظفين واعانه انه راح تسرح 7% او
2,000 موظف يعني فيها وفي ايميل حتى
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه بي باللوم على
البيئه الاقتصاديه الصعبه والخوف من
الركود الاقتصادي اللي بيشهدوا العالم
وكمان حاله عدم اليقين حول الوضع العام
وانخفاض اسهمم او اسهم الشركه اكثر من 50%
العام الماضي الاعلان هذا من شركه
التكنولوجيا عن تسريحه الموظفين والاول
فمن قبل اعلنت اعد الشركات عن تصريح
الالاف من الموظفين واللي منها حتى
التويتر اللي صار راحت 50% من الموظفيها
من بعد ما استلم قال الماسك الشركه وتلقى
7,500 موظفه رسائل بريد الكتروني بالتخلي
عن خدماتهم واما شركه امنتها فكانت اعلنت
كمان عن تسريح 11,000 موظف واللي بتعتبر
اول عمليه تسريح رئيسيه وكبيره في الشركه
ومن بعدها اعلن شركه مايكروسوفت عن
الاستغناء عن 10,000 موظف بسبب تراجع
مبيعاتها جوجل فكمان اعلنت عن تسريحه
12000 موظف من موظفيها كمان بسبب التخلص
من الركود الاقتصادي وحتى امازون اعلنتن
بالخطط او بتخطط التسريح 18000 موظف بسبب
انتهاء ازمه كورونا وانخفاض المبيعات اون
لاين يعني ازمه كبرى وعامه في كل القطاع
الاف المسرحين وكل وسائل الاعلام بس شغاله
دراسه بالتحليل ومحاوله تفهم ايش اللي
جالس بيصير في عالم شركات التقنيه لكن
حقيقه يعني في ظل كل هذا التصريح في شيء
لافتته غريب في نفس الوقت واللي هو انه
قوائم وظائف العام ووظائف المستقبل كلها
جلسه مليانه بوظائف التقنيه بالتحديد حصول
مطور البرمجيات على المركز الاول في قائمه
افضل الوظائف لعام 20 23 20 وفي كيو اس
نيوز بولدي بول وظائف محلل امن المعلومات
مدير اي تي مطور بكل كمان من افضل وظائف
السنه بحسب القائمه هذا غير الكثير من
القوائم الاخرى اللي مليانه ايضا بوظائف
تكنولوجيا فكيف يعني هذه هي وظائف السنه
والمستقبل والمجالات اللي بنشجع الناس
انهم يدرسوها وكل هذه الشركات جلسه بتسرح
موظف فيها يعني كيف نقدر نفسر هذا
الموضوع وهذه الفاجره
عبد العزيز الحمادي الخبير التقني اهلا
فيك معنا عبد العزيز طوال السنوات الماضيه
فعليا كان هذا اللي بينقال انه لازم
تدرسوا برمجه لازم ادخال البرمجه في
المدارس كل هذا الكلام لانه هو هذا
المستقبل الان نحن شايفين قطاع اللي هو
بيعتبر قطاع المستقبل بيستغنى عن موظفينه
كيف نقدر نفهم هذا الشيء
طبعا ااا اختي ساره فعلا الموضوع جدا هامم
والتسريح اللي حصل الماضي لا يعني انه
هناك نهايه عقبه تقنيه المعلومات او
التطور التقني اا ال- ال- هي فقط مرحله
تمر بها اغلب الصناعات على مستوى العالم
والتقنيه في النهائي ليست في معزل عن بقيه
ال- ال- المجالات التسريحات الماضيه يعني
همم لها اسباب كثيره ليست فقط الناحيه
الاقتصاديه وان كان في مؤثر رئيسي لكن
هناك نواحي اخرى على سبيل المثال تطور
السوق وتغير التقنيات الموجوده في جعلت
فعلا مثل هذه الشركات انها تبدا تتوجه الى
يعني تقنيات مجالات اخرى كذلك من الاسباب
المهمه وهي التنافس الكبير في ما بين هذه
الشركات اللي خلق همم تقنيات همم جديد اما
جعل بعض الشركات تتخلى عن تقنيه قديمه
يعني في نفس الحال اكيد بتتخلى عن
الموظفين الذين يقومون عن يقومون على
تشغيل مثل هذه التقنيات اليوم التقنيه
يعني لا تزال في قائمه ابرز المجالات
التقنيه فابرز المجالات الوظيفيه المطلوبه
على مستوى العالم ليس فقط في مجال مثلا
البرمجيات او المجالات التقنيات التي
نعيشها لا ايضا في مجال التقنيات الناشئه
والتقنيات المتطوره على سبيل الذكاء
الاصطناعي على سبيل المثال تعلم الاله على
سبيل المثال الواقع الافتراضي والواقع
المعزز فلذلك الان بدانا في السوق الجديد
بدانا في الثوره الصناعيه ليست فقط
الرابعه انما الخامسه بدانا في ايجاد
شركات راينا قبل فتره
ما الذي احدث من ثوره صناعيه كبيره جدا
جعلت الشركات التقنيه مثل جوجل وفيسبوك
وغيرها من الشركات بدات تتنافس من يعني
يمتلك زمام الامور في هذه التقنيه لدينا
مثلا كمبيوتر او الحوسبه الكموميه
والمنافسه الكبيره جدا ما بين الشركات
جوجل واي بي ام وغيرها من الشركات لمن
سيقود زمام الامور في الحوسبه الكميه
والتي تعتبر
ثوره القادمه في التقنيات همم
التقنيات التي ستقود القادمه لا تزال
الشركات التقنيه
في عرش قائمه من يتحكم في الصناعه همم على
مستوى العالم قائمه افضل شركه اغنى
الشركات التقنيه على المستوى العالم
ثمانيه منها لا تزال شركات تقنيه طيب هذا
اللي بتقول يعني همم يخليني اقول انه يمكن
هذه الشركات طيب وضفت اكثر من ما كانت
تحتاج يعني
طبعا لا هي في وقت توظيفها تحتاج مثل هذه
الطاقات اللي وقدنا على سبيل المثال جوجل
ولا الفيسبوك ولا غيره كان يحتاجون حجم
كبير جدا من الطاقات في بعض التقنيات
المتخصصه في الفتره القادمه مع ال ال ال
يعني الوضع الاقتصادي في الفتره الحاليه
ومع ايضا تغيير التقنيات التي تعمل عليها
هذه الشركات جعلت انه الافضل لها ان
تستثمر في طاقات جديده او انها تقلل
في هذا الموضوع يعني الان مثلا نحنا يكون
موضوع الذكاء الصناعي فالناس تبتدي مثلا
تدخل في مجال دراسه الذكاء الصناعي بعد
شويه يطلع شويه ثاني مثلا ويطيح بالذكاء
الصناعي طب يعني يعني فاهم الدنيا بتتغير
والسرعه بتتغير مره كثيره فا ايش الواحد
يعمل في هذه الحاله يعني
طبعا التقنيه فعلا متغيره بشكل كبير جدا
والتقنيه يعني كل خمس ست سنوات ياتي جيل
جديد مختلف تماما عن الجيل القديم من
ناحيه من ناحيه تقنيه لذلك لابد فعلا يعني
التقني الموظف الذي يمسك جزء تقني معين
يطور نفسه بشكل دوري اليوم مثلا انا تعلمت
على تقنيه معينه بعد سنتين نزل تحديث
تماما مختلف عن التحديث القديم فاذا لم
اطور من نفسي بطبيعه الحال ساكون متاخر
وبالمناسبه الانتقالات التي حصلت لي عشرات
الالاف من المهندسين التقنيين هذا جيد
وسيع
للاشخاص بحداتهم انهم يجب ان يبحث عن
وظائف اخرى ولكن جيد في الموضوع انه هؤلاء
اشخاص سيبداون في وظائف تقنيه اخرى ستخلق
سوق اخر عشرات الالاف من المهندسين
المتميزين والقبرات التقنيه بطريقه خرجوا
من شركه كبيره سيذهبون لشركات همم
او ناشئه ومن ثم يخلقون السوق ومنافسه
اخرى قد تقويد في الفتره القادمه المجالات
التقنيه او عفوا ال ال المجادله التقنيه
المختلفه
على هذه المداخله كان معنا عبر سكايب عبد
العزيز الحمادي الخبير التقني شكرا لك عبد
العزيز
[موسيقى]